well New York City has gotten a lot
dirtier it's not your imagination the
city's leadership is responsible for
this but they've decided to blame
rodents for it they've hired a rat Czar
an identified rat my mitigation zones
there's a local news report explaining
it they're quick dirty disease prone and
above all a nuisance yet rats continue
to make their presence very well known
on New York city streets in some
neighborhoods even more than others the
city plans to zero in on eight areas so
full of vermin the Department of Health
has designated them rat mitigation zones
in Manhattan extra rat fighting patrols
will be on hand in Harlem Chinatown the
East Village and the Lower East Side in
the Bronx Grand Concourse and in
Brooklyn Prospect Heights bedstuy and
Bushwick that's where neighbors were
able to attest Rhoden SAR running
rampant the eight neighborhoods were
deemed high priority thanks to a slew of
3-1-1 calls and complaints about
infestation now those areas will get
more attention from The city-like
increased enforcement on properties that
fail inspections and rat Academy
training free workshops offered by the
Department of Health on rat management
so the question is is New York City
dirty because it has a lot of rats or
does it have a lot of rats because it's
dirty
for a different perspective on this we
thought we would ask Ashley Byrne she
works at Peter where she's the director
of Outreach and she joins us today
Ashley thanks so much for coming on
um I think this is a really interesting
point I don't have a lot of rats in my
house because I don't have a lot of
rotting garbage in my house
and so maybe the problem isn't the rats
it's the people I hadn't thought about
it until you brought it up but if you
wouldn't mind explaining thanks for
having me on Tucker of course exactly
you know the rats are not the problem
the disgusting human behavior that is
attracting the rats that's the problem
we are basically inviting them to be
here by putting out a daily Buffet of
garbage around the city and these
intelligent creatures don't deserve to
die painful excruciating deaths because
of human irresponsibility
or shouldn't we at least I mean even if
you're not going to go as far as you're
going
and you're I think at the place where
you're saying let's not kill the rats
even if you're kind of for maybe killing
some rats couldn't we also do our part
as people and like not leave pizza
slices on the sidewalk and pick up the
garbage regularly why why shouldn't we
play in a role too exactly you know as
long as we don't clean up our act the
city can kill as many rats as it wants
to it's just going to keep coming back
you know this is this is nothing more
than a quick fix if killing rats worked
we wouldn't have a rat problem because
people have already been killing rats in
the city for decades but we live under
mountains of garbage so they have not
gone away and they won't
who do you and you obviously study
animal behavior do you think long term
the rats are smarter than the leadership
of the city or the city's leadership
smarter than the rats
well I'll say this rats are actually
very clean animals and they're smart
enough not to treat their homes like a
garbage dump so I'll leave it at that
Ashley bernapeda you know you guys have
this reputation for being so extreme I
didn't think that was extreme I thought
that was a really good point and I'm
glad that you came on tonight thank you
thanks so much Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight